another question this one's from matthew
you often talk
about founders needing to be in silicon
valley in order to cl
to be close to the action sort of like
needing to be in vegas or la
to get into the big poker games post
covid
how does this change do places like
sydney vancouver beijing become
game change cities great question
matthew so i always advised
you know i would say up until maybe
three or four years ago if you're going
to start a company come to silicon
valley
deal with the high rents and be close to
the power not
their money would available very quick
if they were here but they would be near
a lot of money and they would get more
money and
it would work out i think uh to still be
here but
taking the money from san francisco
let's say you raised a million dollars
and you bring it back to canada or you
bring it to florida or austin or some
other place
and you run a remote company well you
can see the efficiency and so
we didn't have the sense back then
that more than five or ten companies
would be remote first
and the ones that remote first it often
felt like they were leaving
something on the table uh facebook uber
microsoft google
youtube i don't think that these
companies would have hit scale
true meaningful venture scale if they
were virtual
um first and or they were work from home
first
now if everybody chooses to be work from
home that does change the
context it does change the system we're
all operating in
but i still don't know if those
companies would have been built now
people will point to envision
or um wordpress my friend matt's company
and the cynical take on that was well
maybe if matt mullenweg had a
a company that was all in one place
maybe their company would be bigger
maybe with a 10 billion dollar company
now that's a bit of a cynical take
um and i don't know that i share it but
i don't also disagree that
um if everybody's in the room things can
work better so i think
hybrid is what things will be in the
future
and what's going to happen for companies
is when they become
work from home or hybrid which will be i
think hybrid becomes the default
they will learn how to now that they've
learned how to manage remote workers
they're going to see which workers over
perform and underperform because
you don't get to see somebody in the
office for 60 hours a week and say that
person's killing it because they came in
at eight and they left at eight or they
did nine to nine
where they were here on the weekend that
was how we judged people previously now
we're going to judge them on the work
and the output
that you see in their reporting and you
see in their end of the day report and
end of week report
and in slack so things have changed
and if you can hire people
anywhere that means you're going to hire
people i believe for
30 40 50 000 less than you will
in san francisco and then eventually
people get so good at this
they might be good at uh managing people
in other countries and maybe
people who maybe english as a second
language if you're
an american company or japanese is a
second language if you're a japanese
company et cetera
so i think this does uh take the silicon
valley operating system and spread it a
little bit further i think companies
will be more nimble they'll have a lower
cost basis they'll get rid of their
office space and they'll be able to hire
quicker and people will stay with
companies longer
for certain people the flexibility of
working from home is great for other
people it's maddening it's for me it's
maddening to be at home every day i want
to get out of the house
i want to meet people but my job is very
interactive for other people
you know if you're a writer or if you're
a developer
uh maybe you don't want to be around
other people maybe you just want to
concentrate and
maybe introverts want to work from home
extroverts want to work in the office
it could be um you know as simple as
that and
um it will be a big change i do believe
we're going to get through the covert
thing relatively quickly
i think we're going to solve it i think
this time next year um
let's call it third quarter of
2021 we will be making jokes about
coronavirus and saying you know why to
corona and
oh wasn't that hilarious we all thought
we were going to die and
it was you know we solved it and look
the world's amazing and we we know
better for the future so
hopefully we do figure this one out and
everything goes back to normal
and then we learn a couple of new skills
in our skill set
but one of the great things uh that's
happening in san francisco right now is
i heard rents are down 10 to 20
in the middle of this crisis because
people just left people who are on
month-to-month leases left
so when and then i heard conversely in
some places like tahoe or other places
maybe
rents went up because people were
looking to go other places
that means a younger generation or
people who maybe were priced out of the
city who are taking long commutes
they can now live in the city or live
closer to work and
i believe that is gonna make
you know maybe san francisco will feel
like it did after the last two busts
after the
combust and after 2008 and that bust
where people
it felt a little more affordable and
that's not a bad thing boom bus cycles
are a good thing
but i think cities uh are still going to
win the day
maybe that's a contrarian position but i
think
cities win the day